are you happy
absolutely I'm just here it's actually
it's difficult to make me
unhappy now I could deal with
frustrations
but when those frustrations are it's
like
when you've allowed people to be in your
life that shouldn't be there
and then they do the thing you knew they
were going to do and you're screaming at
them but you really need to scream at
yourself
hmm yeah so you realize anything that's
like anger or frustration that's
something that's wrong with you that
needs to be dealt with
yes like right now okay say I got this
pattern cutter that I wanted
to remove because I felt like she was
copying our patterns into the computer
and I didn't know why she wanted to do
that and I just wanted to do the
patterns by hand
and then you know you mean like
automating the patterns is that yeah am
I ahead of it because they just that's
the whole thing it's like
it's a war of it's a war of human beings
and robots yeah but that makes it more
efficient right you don't like the
efficiency you like the creativity of
the singular nature of the pattern I
believe that the human beings and I'm
saying this to you as a person who makes
robots and a person is friends right now
yeah well yeah I'll let it go okay good
so yeah I believe that the yay hates
robots
I'm not gonna put that out it's a joke
robots have feelings too yeah yeah
that's right that was also a joke was it
wouldn't you clarify that from future
robots but the pattern cutter the
pattern cutter you don't like that it
had to be that that's you can't have
that part of your life
that's not what I'm I'm my everything
that I'm doing is for
the sake of the human race
there's things in capitalism there's
things
and Technology well tech technology and
original human species can exist
in a peaceful way
as long as the people that know how to
make robots aren't using their robots to
control the humans